you look around you see everyone wearing
masks you say oh my gosh
this is really really bad biden has
promised you're gonna have another 100
days of masking
who knows maybe you'll have more than
that some public health experts
are saying we're always going to wear
masks on airplanes
the hysteria is still growing there was
there was a poor young millennial gal
who was
in an elevator wearing a mask and there
was another millennial gal it was a
little more reasonable
and she she had a mat she had the mascot
i guess in an inappropriate way or it
wasn't totally covering her nose
the millennial masker had a complete
nervous breakdown
you are a delivery person incorrectly
wearing the mask inside
is this is this incorrectly worn guys is
this incorrectly worn
that wasn't like that the whole time
oh man
i love this delivery gal who just says
like oh looks fine to me i guess she had
pulled it up or something by the time
she turned
the odds that this screaming millennial
will die from the virus are
statistically zero zero percent
the odds that she gets a little sniffle
and a cough if she even gets the virus
or that's about the worst that's about
the worst thing that's that's likely to
happen her and yet she's freaking out
that is a different epidemic it's not
the epidemic of coronavirus it's the
epidemic of hysteria
and that didn't come to us by way of
china that came to us by way of
democrats
and elected or unelected public health
bureaucrats
that needs to end the risk of that
hysteria
the risk of demagogues taking more and
more power
the risk of elections never having very
much integrity again if we have voting
season that goes on for months
and no verification and no transparency
and no
oversight and computers that we can't
really look into all that well
and polling locations that we can't look
into all that well and state
constitutions that are violated
that is a far all of that is a greater
threat and don't forget all the election
shenanigans were justified
on the premise of coronavirus that is a
far greater threat
than the virus and that's what we need
to stand up against
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]